congratulations on season two of single
parents this is amazing thank you how
does it feel going into season two
compared to season one
it feels good we get to kind of focus on
everyone's characters and sort of like a
smaller way like each detailed adventure
that they go on I'm instead of kind of
meeting and greeting every character you
really already know everyone so it's fun
it's funny and I feel like we already
have like so many great little inside
jokes so you've seen the first season
like you can come in the second season
and if you haven't that's okay Jo like
okay we welcome everyone
um but this season my character is as
she's like come face to face with her ex
who is her son's dad who she's like kind
of built up in her head into everyone
else to be this like awful person and
she comes face to face with him and
she's like maybe he's not so bad
she decides to write him like a very
rageful email and he may come back into
her life again so that was what's
happening this season and of course the
ex is your real-life husband my ex yet
what is it like being on set with your
husband is it is it strange is that okay
do you love it you hate it it's no one's
gonna know it's gonna be totally fine
yeah it's great it's great I really love
working with him no it's really good I
mean um I mean it's like I he's my best
friend and it's my favorite place
besides home with my own family like
this is my work family it's where I go
you know 12 hours a day
Muncy air so like bringing him to see
everybody else that I'm with all day is
like amazing and it's kind of a guest of
honor and yeah so it's really nice I
really like it nice people have really
identified with your character actually
everybody on the show people a lot of
single parents have really you know
gravitated towards the show did you
expect
sort of this reception from people I in
particular hear it from single parents
quite a lot like I'll just you know
whenever I meet people you know for
other reasons I'm sure people enjoy the
show because it kind of have something
for everyone I'm not a single parent
myself no it's funny we did yes funny
write up funny
a very you know heartwarming and
wonderful in that way but also I think
you know portraying single parents on TV
we don't see that a lot so it's really
cool to see and obviously to talk to
people who experience it the good and
the bad which you know there's there's
so much of both and just hearing their
own personal stories and in particular
from single moms just like it makes me
so happy is there any piece whether it
be through the writing or just through
being with your characters that you've
learned about single parents that you
didn't know before I mean you know a
single mom and I I've done it a handful
of times like for extended periods would
you basically just like my husband's out
of town and I think it's the hardest
thing it is the hardest it is so hard
it's just like you you know your kids
sick or can't make it to school so you
have to figure out a sitter and you
really don't have time if you're working
as well to spend time doing anything
other than working and raising your kid
there's not like a oh but I'm also gonna
like gonna have me time no me I didn't
get me time I don't understand it
especially when the husband's traveling
I don't understand yeah I know you don't
like you're like I know I won't see my
friends yeah I can't do that yeah um and
you know I mean work is almost like it's
only occasion in a way cuz like at least
you can sit and have a cup of coffee
like with a kid you're running around
after a kid but I think the most um I
think the thing I've learned not
necessarily surprising is that there are
obviously so many hard times because you
know having a kid there's so many ups
and downs but the good times I think I
think that would even be hard to like
all the all the milestones that it's
like you kind of look around and
obviously you know in Angie's case on my
show like she has a whole village if you
know if people who are around supporting
her but everything is kind of left up to
to her to be there for the good times to
you know like you lose your first two
through you get a part in the school
play and it's kind of just you you know
and so that's its own challenge but I
think she's taken out on really well I
guess the mom and the dad and the
everything absolutely fans are really
wondering what's going to happen with
will and Angie can you give us any
there's a lot of people
really want this to happen they do I
would like it to happen to you would
yeah I would too I don't know because I
don't write the show but I think that
that is a very slow burn that we're kind
of playing with I think what's
interesting right now is seeing the two
of them just being friends you know
something that you don't see often which
is just like people becoming friends
than best friends kind of bringing out
the best and in times worse each other
but um but there's definite like a spark
I think that them you know having the
same type of background and manage and
opposites in many ways but they have a
lot of fun and I don't know I would like
to see what happens I'd like to see you
too guys yeah there you go but there is
something really beautiful happening on
your show that needs to happen on more
shows
everyone is getting paid equally what
does that do for morale on the show I'd
say it's good I feel good about it I
know that I'm paid the same as my male
co-stars hmm which it doesn't hurt that
we have the same agents I think that's
sort of part of it they were like what
this comes as a package but I think it's
good I I don't think that it makes you
know I think that like I would put
forward the same quality of work but I
think that it's just right that that why
not why why shouldn't we be you know
it's also amazing to be on set with we
have a woman showrunner executive
producers writers and directors and it's
just a wonderful environment to feel you
know sort of equal footing mm-hmm yeah
very supportive
aside from television you also have been
in music for a long time any chance on
another album coming out or working on
anything yes I'm working on music now
music that I've written over the past
couple years I'm recording now um so
hopefully I don't know in the next year
or so I'll be putting it out nice well
congratulations on everything and thanks
for coming in thank you
you